[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and i will be your driver on this
journey uh it's an exciting night here
tonight because i am talking about some
of the fundamentals and then we're gonna
take a look at how those fundamentals
really break down some incredibly
complex king and pawn end games of
course king and pawn end games are kind
of chess at its most pure there's not a
lot of pieces to think about the pieces
that are left kings and pawns don't move
in a lot of different ways you know
they're they're short range pieces they
they take their time and that really
allows you to go deep into the position
and and kind of get the the full truth
and get the truth of the matter in king
and pawn end games there's no you know
white is slightly better black is
slightly better it's either winning it's
drawn or it's losing so that's what
we're going to talk about here tonight
uh and first and foremost i have a quick
little warm up for you guys uh this is
an ancient game between duras and
spielman
and i just wanted to highlight this
because it shows that uh funny mistakes
in the most basic positions are are
possible for everyone
so in this position spielman actually
plays the move rook to f4 and this is
pretty indicative
of you know our our
first instinct in a lot of positions
where we're defending of course white is
defending here white is down upon
and when you're defending it's really
tempting to try and simplify things get
to get to the simplest position and then
and then draw but of course
rook f4 is actually a huge mistake so
it's black to move and win here
let's see what you guys got
can you find the wind
so of course the idea is we want to
trade into a king and pawn end game
uh but we want it to be the one that's
actually winning can't be a draw
hello hello thanks for coming out
so we're looking at this position white
just played this move rook f4 and i'm
explaining that this is a massive
mistake because black to move wins
and okay the youtube chat is is on to it
so
uh you might think the best you can do
is to take on f4 here uh but white's
gonna take back and then we're actually
not winning this end game of course this
is one of the basic king and pawn end
game positions and whenever the white
king is in front of the pawn you're not
going to be able to drive him away
and eventually
you're going to get to
stalemate of course
just play it out here
check white steps back in front of the
pawn and then we have to move our king
we cannot move the pawn and we have to
defend our pawn which results in
stalemate and draw so one of the most
basic draws
now
our improvement of course is we can go
king g5 here passing the move back to
white
and this is really powerful because for
one we are now threatening to take the
rook and after white takes here
we have the opposition our king is in
front of the pawn and that's going to
allow us to win we can use our king to
escort the pawn down the board
so there you go there's your warm up
there's your warm up
and let us continue on now i want to
talk about uh a couple simpler concepts
in king and pawn end games and then
we're going to try to combine those
concepts into
a very complex end game so to start with
uh hopefully a lot of you know about the
outside past pawn so does anybody in the
live audience know about that quote
unquote outside past pawn
have you heard of this idea
kind of okay
so who has the outside past pawn in this
position white or black
yeah it's white right we have this pawn
it's
the outside past pawn because it's
further away from the remaining pawns on
the board you know black does not have
the outside pass pawn because it's
closer to those pawns than white's pawns
uh then white's a pawn
so
how can we use the past pawn the outside
past pawn to win the game in this
position it's it's white to move
what can we do in order to to win
why is it advantageous to have this pawn
that's so far away
i guess because if you if you trade with
that pie
the king's gonna have to take you
okay
uh so you're on the right track but like
you know so what black takes it what
does that what does that get us
what's the point
yeah that that's exactly right so we're
using we're using the outside pass pawn
is something called a decoy or a
distraction we're not actually going to
promote our outside past pawn because
black's going to be able to stop it
but what this pawn is useful for is it
draws the king further away from the
action
and as we saw from the first puzzle you
know it can be a matter of a single turn
that's going to determine if you're
winning or if you're you're drawing and
that's going to be the case here so we
don't actually want to play a5 first
because black can take
and it can actually come back just in
time to defend his pawn
but what we can do is really play any
move but king c4 makes the most sense
and the point now is that black tries to
defense and now we're just going to
launch this pawn forward allow black to
come take it
but at the end of the day
black's king is going to be way over
here
and in this end game we can come over
and black's going to try to chase us but
of course black is just going to be way
too slow here our king's in front of the
pawn again we have that basic winning
position
so this is a pretty simple concept in
king and pawn end games if you have the
outside past pawn that's going to be
advantageous now it's not always good
enough for a win depends a lot on the
position of the kings but it's
advantageous to have the outside
past pawn
now i want to introduce uh another
simple concept here and this position
isn't exactly like you know from a real
game or anything and it's not even
particularly interesting but i want to
show you uh sort of what's going on here
so i'm showing you this position from
black's perspective for some reason
don't really know why i did that
um so the white pawn is coming down the
black pawn is is coming up and this is
one of the simplest versions of what i
want to call
uh mutual zooxvong so if you guys heard
about zooxvong
in the in person audience here
yeah okay so what zugsvang is if you're
not familiar
is you are i'm going to say zugged now
because it's easier um you're zugged
you're in zugsvang if
all of your moves hurt your position if
you would rather say pass and hit your
clock then make a move then you're
you're in zhuxwang
and mutual zugzwang is a special case of
this
where neither side wants to move
and so this is actually going to be a
case of mutual zugzwang we're going to
reach a position where neither side
actually wants to move
so let's let's look from white's
perspective for a second i'm going to
flip the board don't get whiplash um
so what's the most natural move for
white just not even thinking ahead what
do you want to do with your with your
king
yeah you want to come to d4 you want to
take d5 and then you want to like play
with the pawn
uh but of course what is black's most
natural response to this move
yeah king e6 and now we we've actually
attained our mutual zugzwan now in this
very very simple case it doesn't really
matter because white is still drawing
and now do you guys see why white's
still drawing what should we play
well i guess it doesn't matter but we
can play anything black can take this
pawn
but now of course white's not going to
let the black king get in front of the
pawn we can box them out and again we
just get a simple draw
it's a it's a german word yeah um
zugsvang is
uh
z-w-a-n-g yeah sorry i had to think
about it there
um
yeah leave it to the the scrabble
champion to spell the words but uh okay
so these are the simple concepts so keep
these ideas in mind this idea of mutual
zooxvan
uh this idea of the outside past pawn
and this idea of trading down into a
favorable end game okay so we're to look
at that and now we're going to go to a
real game so this is a game between mark
tymanov and mikhail bodfenik uh of
course hopefully you guys have heard of
these players botfinik famous world
champion simonov also very famous chess
player don't think it was a world
champion but i might might have just
embarrassed myself
so i don't care about any of this this
is like all the normal chess game that's
not we're here for tonight
okay we're getting closer
getting closer to the end game
okay
so we can start talking stop talking
about the position here so right now we
have a rook end game
and this is something that's uh that's
common to pretty much every kingdom pawn
end game they come from end games that
were not quite king and pawn end games
so at some point you're always going to
have to trade the last piece off so pay
attention to what they're doing with the
rooks
and then eventually there's going to be
a really key moment
where black can offer a trade so the
first thing i want to point out
black brings his rook to the second rank
it's where the rooks are are the best
even in the middle game usually in the
end game as well
and the idea is you're able to attack
all of these pawns and none of the pawns
can defend each other on the second rank
that's why it's so strong and then he
does this nice move of e3
so what this does is it takes his double
pawns and it sacrifices one of them in
order to grant the rook access to these
pawns on the king's side so we get takes
on e3 takes on e2
and now h4 by white so
white could have taken on a6
but this end game is actually just going
to be completely lost for white and the
reason is
we have connected past pawns which is
hopefully another term you might have
heard in the past so these pawns work
really well together rolling on down the
board and in the meanwhile
black is going to be able to stop this
a2 pawn very effectively just by sliding
the rook over to get behind the pawn so
rook a6 is no good that's why white
plays h4
and now this is the first spot where i
want to turn the question back over to
you guys
black to move here see if you can come
up with a very strong plan
to try and win this position
and you might not think that this is a
king and pawn end game but it's
important to always be calculating the
king and pawn end games in these
positions
so we need a plan to win the game
h5 would work g4
yeah there you go so um let's let's take
one step back first though so
abstractly you know which pawn would we
like to win the most
yeah we want to win the h pawn for that
reason that i just mentioned if we get
these connected past pawns we're going
to be winning
so you know a move like
rook h2 is one way to try to go about it
but white is actually perfectly happy to
just um
come chase our rook away and white
doesn't even
care probably about this e pawn he's
going to be able to take here and it's
one past pawn to one passed pawn right
now you know obviously this end game is
not going to be pleasant for white but a
lot better holding chances
then um you know something like like
this position for example where we have
the connected past pawns together so we
really want to win the h pawn
um and so what brian just suggested
is is pretty interesting so whenever you
have an end game uh
with you know one or a couple pieces on
the board something that's really
important is to be thinking
what happens if we trade these pieces
okay and now that's really important
because if the peace trade favors you if
the peace trade makes your position
winning then you can use that as a tool
to you know achieve your aims so here
our aim is to go after the h4 pawn and
you know brian said he's just wagering a
guess but
in a real game you would want to be
calculating say okay
these rooks come off the board am i
winning and in this case uh hopefully
the answer is yes so the plan that brian
came up with is very very clever so the
rook is defending the h4 pawn along the
rank
and so what brian wants to do is he
wants to offer the rook trade in which
case white can trade down into a king
and pawn end game or white's gonna have
to give up this pawn he he can't have it
both ways
so this is a really useful resource in
pretty much every end game you want to
be thinking
does the peace trade favor me and if it
does favor you that's going to give you
a lot more options to to achieving your
goals like taking the h4 upon or even
just something simple like advancing the
king
so h5 brilliant move by botfineck
in the game taimanov tries king f1
and botvanek continues on with rook to
g4
okay now we're gonna get uh rook takes
on g4
and pawn takes on g4
and king to g2 so congratulations you uh
traded off the rooks now the question is
uh how are you actually winning in this
this king and pawn end game so that's
the next thing we're going to be looking
at here
how do we deal
with this king and pawn end game was
brian right are we actually winning or
is there more to the story
so as you start thinking here my advice
is to always start with the natural
moves just because i'm showing it to you
in a class
you might be thinking okay so maybe the
natural moves aren't correct but you
should start with them to try and
understand what's going on in the
position
so what's natural here
yeah you want to bring the king up so
let's let's start with this so what
happens on king f6 so so take a minute
to try and think it through
keeping in mind those basic ideas that i
shared at the start of the class
well no not just white's move but but
what's going on in this end game try to
calculate a few moves ahead
see who uh who king f6 is really going
to favor
um
um
yeah so this is where it gets tough
because the sun game is a lot harder
than the ones we were looking at because
well
actually it might be kind of dangerous
even though i don't think that the king
is moving to f6 to
possibly make the next move prior to g
five but
yeah so let's let's take a look at king
f6 and let's just start even simpler
than g5 so king f6
white wants to play king g3 right you
know he wants to come take this this
pawn
and so let's say king f5 is played
so let's try and figure out what's going
on here
uh so before we figure out what's going
on
uh does this configuration of the kings
look at look familiar at all from
earlier in the class yeah right so this
is one of those times where it's mutual
zugzwan
so whoever can can make the enemy king
sort of blink first lose the game of
chicken is potentially going to have
either an advantage or or at least
um some some extra ideas some additional
ideas
so
white has a resource here yeah go ahead
well i'm thinking about
i'm thinking about e4 maybe
yeah e4 is is definitely an important
resource so
you know we didn't necessarily run black
out of moves but this king can no longer
stay uh in contact with the g4 pawn it's
the most natural is going to be to take
uh we can take on g4
and what's gonna happen is we get into
this race
both sides are going to come
and it looks like white is just in time
to not be losing the game
just in time now black can actually win
a pawn here
okay maybe maybe not with check
but this end game is is actually just
gonna be a draw uh black's not gonna be
able to to promote this this a pawn
uh while escaping the checks and let me
just double check yeah table base agrees
total draw now obviously in an objective
game
uh it depends on how good the players
are if they manage to make a draw here
but black doesn't want to draw because
black has extra pawns so king f6 king f5
is not going to be good enough because
white does have this resource and then
at the end of the day both sides are
going to clean
okay so the most natural plan doesn't
work
so the question is is there another plan
that does here
is there another plan that might work
for black
okay so king to g7 let's let's calculate
a little bit again uh what happens if
king g3
king h6 okay now i'm starting to think
white's better right white takes your
pawn and then he actually has a little
bit more space
because this king is slightly further up
the board
so we gotta be a little bit more clever
yeah so we don't really have time to go
to the other side because of the the
same thing why it's going to come take
these pawns promote the h-pawn
and we're never in time
uh
pawn to e5 okay
uh white's always going to be doing the
same thing here white's not going to
change his game plan
and not sure you have anything
much just going to be taken
it's a little too slow
so here's uh here's my hint okay you saw
the position with the kings on g3 and g5
the problem there for black was that
white has this move e4 with check
now if uh
this move isn't check if we have some
other kind of mutual zugzwang
then it's going to become a race to see
who can run the other side out of tempe
so
we're looking for some other way let's
put white in zooxvong
where we we can have our kings some
square other than f5
g5 yeah that's actually exactly right
here pawn to g5 is is what was played in
the game
um and now i i do want to mention after
king f6 king g3 you actually mentioned
potentially playing g5 here and just
want to say shout out to you that's also
winning but it's a little bit
less uh
clean because it's
you're sort of masking the idea g5 is
the idea in either line and might as
well play it right away
uh so let's start with the simple line
what what happens if white's taking our
pawn
just king g6 right
here here we have the outside past pawn
we win the game we come take the other
pawns and promote
uh so hg5 is no good
so let's think about some other moves
for for wyatts there's two other main
options here to consider
yeah i mean i i
would i couldn't really see what to do
okay so h5 is one of the options what's
what's the other move we have to be
worried about
yeah you do have to calculate king g3 so
kg3 is a bit simpler so let's let's
start with that idea
okay shiny chameleon is
trying to get ahead of me here but i
think his line features an illegal move
so you might want to check that again
chameleon
don't think king g6 is legal there
so
all right do we just like
do do we just uh do g takes h and then
like while he's taking us
okay so g takes h um i think white's to
take this guy let's just calculate a
little bit here
here
here king f3
maybe we can be a little bit more
efficient with the tempe
a little bit more efficient
yeah i think so um so king g3 king f6
and we'll look at h5 but first let's
start with this line
white just takes
obviously this is no good so white takes
now we're going to take
and we've drawn this king this way i
think we actually gained like two full
tempe here
and so if i'm not mistaken
um
if i go here
and push my guy
what about the e5 before
uh which position
so the king can't go to oh here
uh yeah e5 might be worth it i actually
want to leave my pawn here so white has
to spend more time to come take it there
might be more than one win here but uh
okay we can even say a4 for example
um say king e4
we're way ahead in this pawn race
way ahead
and again what what idea was that that
that we had here to win the game
it's
it's the outside past pawn we could
distract the king away and
let me just do a quick engine check to
make sure i didn't say anything too
ridiculous there
yeah and you win here just by by doing
exactly the plan i just said you push
this pawn you take the a pawn and you
clean
okay always good to make sure i'm not
lying to you guys
um but there's this other idea of h5
which is a little bit harder to uh to
deal with by the way you can also get
this position and it's going to be
largely the same but okay let's say h5
first that's what was played in the game
so what are we doing now what's what's
the point of our play
yeah no he's he's getting this guy he's
definitely getting this guy so it's like
i mean i would definitely go for that
pawn over there but
that's real close too
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
um
so
uh okay so i'm thinking
we play king g7 uh
king g3
king h6 king takes g4 then we have this
mutual zoo swan and then we're going to
use the fact we're going to reserve our
e coin because we can move it twice if
we want to okay
so this is the the zum to aim for right
you're good um
so this is the mutual zigzag that that
we want so now you know e4s never check
for white right and that's that's great
for us
um but here let's let's try and
calculate a little bit i feel like
something may be a miss in this position
um
yeah i'm gonna have to use my brain on
this one
because it did not prep this line in
particular but let's try and figure out
what's going on so brian wants to
save the e pawn back here because it can
either step two squares or one square
depending on what the situation calls
for
so he wanted to play this way
but i'm curious now what happens
after this move
what happens after e4
okay e5 a4
the same object
right
e6 e5
well at this point it's we're all or
nothing we're all in on this these kings
over here either i'm going to win this
pawn and i win or you're going to win
this punt and you win so it's just about
making sure your opponent has to move
first
so i think
e4 okay well let's let's continue this
line so what is black play here
yeah black to move
okay
and now you're in trouble right now
you're in trouble now white has the
outside pass pawn and we're going to get
distracted trying to stop it and then
i'll take our other pawns and win
so let's come back here
and see if we can improve on that line
that line's the right idea it's the
right idea
but it's hard to make it work okay and
there's one more line we should look at
i guess
um so i was saying a5 e4
and someone was asking what happens if
a4
and here i think that this move might
actually give you some some problems
because if you go a3 i go e6 if you go
e6 i go a3 and same deal
same deal
so can we improve on that line
okay and black white can come up
g7
uh but maybe white can be clever here
yeah so king g4 king h6 i think this is
what we want right we want it to be
white's turn here because last time it
was our turn
we had to waste our tempe
but now maybe white can just pass
so we want to achieve this position
with white to move oh okay so we just go
to h7 the king can't like that's exactly
right so
uh so just like in the other line where
white was going to pass here black has
the option to pass and unfortunately for
white due to the way just the nature of
pawns
white cannot waste a turn here you can't
pass with the king before taking because
the pawn covers that square
and also this square so white is forced
to take
now we can go king h6
and the question is are we winning in
this end game
and how do we do it which pawn do we
move how far do we move it
okay well actually it's white's turn
sorry white plays e4
and now it's up to us which pawn to move
and how far to move it
now is my idea correct that we should
save the e4 yes so the important thing
here is i forgot that they had also a
second rank
yeah so so the important thing here is
you know one of these moves either
moving the e pawn or moving the a pawn
is by far objectively better so in these
sort of tempo
i don't want to call them races but you
know when reserve tempe are important
when it's important to have more tempe
in reserve tempe that you can waste
when that's important it's really
effective to have a pawn on its starting
square
because imagine the scenario where these
pawns are are locked
now if
they're locked i can jump two squares
and make it white's turn now if these
pawns are one square apart
i can waste my time just a little bit
play e6
and now it is white that has to move and
i have another another tempo over here
so having this option to go one or two
squares is really really useful
so in this case it's good to move the a
pawn because you want to keep those that
option in in reserve
but here it's doubly important because
as
brian was mentioning now white also has
that that same resource which is why we
were losing in the other line
um so not only are we
keeping our tempi in reserve
but by pushing this pawn we are taking
away white's choice to move one or two
squares white no longer has that choice
and so we can just win effectively in
this position so a5 was played
um a5
okay this was was not all played let me
go back
ah okay in the game e4 was played and
white resigned
but i think this is worth
worth looking at here so should we go a5
or e5 of course we should go a5
and now a4
white's turn he can take his pick of
things to do
but i want to take a look at uh king f5
here so let's see what's going on in
this position so we can take
but all of a sudden you might be asking
yourself
okay never mind we just won the tempo we
won the tempe race i think there's one
more line that can be tricky in this
position but
i think what we have is is good enough
so there you go this is a very complex
end game right
you know that that took quite a bit of
time to sort of untangle but when you
break it down it's it's not not so crazy
it's made up of these simpler concepts
this idea of zug's vong this idea of
keeping tempe in reserve this idea of
having the outside pass pawn to distract
the enemy king away
and before that we had this idea of
threatening to trade down to achieve
your aims so
those four building blocks all kind of
come together
in this complex end game so does anybody
have questions on this end game and how
those ideas are all kind of coming
together to make a position
any questions at all
okay sounds good let us let us move
along so now
i want to introduce
uh another simple idea to you and then i
want to show you a position from
actually a blitz game that i played a
long time ago sometimes you get
interesting positions so
how many of you have heard about uh like
a box rule of some kind in in king and
pawn end games
brian has ben has so the rule you've
probably heard has to do with with past
pawns right you can draw a diagonal line
from the pawn to the end of the board
turn that into a box
and if the enemy king is within that box
he can catch your pawn before your pawn
makes it to the end of the board if it's
outside that box then you're going to
win because you you can you can queen
but i have a different type of of box
rule devretsky calls it the floating
square
if you know that guy
and this rule has to do with when you
have two pawns left and they can be two
squares apart they can be one square
apart
three squares apart uh you have to
double check for me but but i think the
rule rule holds there as well
so the rule in this case
is you make the same kind of box
and does anybody know
what's important about the box what what
this rule entails
okay i'm just asking if if you already
know the rule if you don't know the rule
you're not going to be able to like
guess what it what it is but you know
what's important with with the box here
yes
so if this box reaches the end of the
board
then your pawns are going to promote
without being caught the enemy king will
not be able to stop you from promoting
your pawns if the box reaches the end of
the board the box does not reach the end
of the board your pawns can be caught
and in this case they can actually be be
captured okay so that's the rule
would you say there are two spaces
so they're two space two spaces in the
middle this rule also works if there's
one space in the middle
um three spaces apart is sort of a lot
rarer i i do believe that that the rule
holds up there it should hold up there
um the thing that's different about
having the pawns uh just one space apart
is that they can occasionally defend you
defend each other um meaning here i i
can show that after we show this but in
this case
uh white is actually losing in this
position because black is able to
capture these pawns so let's see what
happens so a5 is the best try for white
you want to push the pawn how is the
black king catching the pawns here
what move do we play
but yeah
king b5 that's right
um now if we push this guy
and now we're in the other box the other
kind of box rule
so no matter what white does black is
going to be capturing all your pawns
if you try to weights
i'm just going to come here
and now white can go a5
and how does black win this position
obviously if we didn't push a5 black was
just going to take our pawn
yeah we step back
now e4 is too slow
because we're in the box
and so we can pass
but now king b5 again
and it's the same it's just the same so
white is losing here no way to keep
these pawns
but if we see we move one little pawn up
one little square
uh it's white to move and now actually
win so of course what's the move
yeah you play d5 now the bach box
reaches the end of the board and just to
prove that that it's not all a big scam
if you try the same idea
of uh you know going after the pawns
we'll try king b7 just to be clever i
can push
push
and now you are not in my box i i saved
saved one row and white of course is
gonna queen and there's actually no way
for uh for black to stop these pawns if
you go after this guy i come here if you
try to come back i can actually check
now
because again you're not catching my
pawn
so that's the box rule so i want you to
keep this idea in mind as we look at
this just completely random blitz game i
played a long time ago
so the game itself isn't important it
wasn't particularly well played or
anything but we did reach a very
interesting endgame
so rook f2
king f8s b4 h5 a4 h4
a5 g5
uh and then here
uh by the way just just for your
information uh white is actually winning
so if you want a little puzzle for
yourself white to move and win instead
my opponent played a bad move rook d2
and that's what we're going to focus on
so of course class tonight is about king
and pawn end games i took the rook black
took the rook and now
let's pause a moment and just sort of
figure out what's going on in this
position
so there's another really really
important idea which i
didn't create a simple example for
and that idea is the idea of a
breakthrough so in this position neither
side has any past pawns i have extra
pawns on the king side but they're not
exactly passed yet you know the enemy
pawns can still catch them
and white has two extra c pawns on the
queen side but again
they are are not passed so
the idea of a breakthrough is using
those extra pawns or sometimes even the
same number of pawns sometimes even
fewer pawns but using your pawns to
sneak past the enemy pawn so you want to
create an opening so that you have a
past pawn
so that's going to be incredibly
important to this position and that box
rule that i just told you about the
floating square is also going to be very
very important in this end game
so with that in mind yet go ahead i was
just gonna ask like
i mean it's a blitz game but like maybe
for a longer game is that kind of like
what you're already thinking about here
or or like
like a an advanced like already be
thinking about like
the box
okay so i wouldn't the the floating
square idea is definitely not the first
thing that comes to mind now this idea
of breakthroughs that's definitely the
first thing that you're thinking about
so the first thing you look at here in a
game is you say okay how can my opponent
make a past pawn and am i able to catch
it with my king
then you're thinking okay can i make a
past pawn and how can the the enemy uh
king catch it and if there's no simple
way to win meaning there's no way to
just make a pass pawn and win then you
have to get more creative and that's
where ideas like the floating square are
going to come into play
but to start with i'm sorry so you want
to start like envisioning what kind of
uh pawn structure you could come up with
on one side of the board eventually yeah
uh you want to be able to keep the the
enemy king sort of sort of locked and
you want to make sure that definitely
the enemy king can't like come in and
actually capture any of your pawns like
that's that's the bare minimum that you
want and then after that you're thinking
okay well okay how can i actually make
any progress but first and foremost
you know start on the defensive side is
white making threats on the queen's side
do we actually need our king closer to
the queen side so what is white's idea
what is white's quote-unquote threat
come up with some some breakthrough
ideas
ways to break through
like let's say black passes
which f6 not quite a pass but it's as
close as i'm gonna get
all right one idea has been shown in the
chat so continue on with that idea chat
what happens if if white plays that move
yes so this is the the first move that
comes to mind right this pawn on b7 is
stopping your c pawns from advancing
so natural is to try to play a6
now black can capture black can play b6
but if you take
uh then you have a past c pawn but in
this case this isn't so scary right i
can just bring my king and i'm in this
box
like what's what's the big deal
what's the big deal you can play this i
mean i can come here
and then actually you're just losing
trivially i just play a6
i take all your pawns i have two extra
pawns
i'm gonna win the game
so a6 actually isn't so scary a6 isn't
scary at all but
there's there's something else that that
might give you pause here
c6 was
i
okay so c6 could be interesting uh so
what's happening there what if we take
e5
ah okay so b5
um so i'm going to try to be clever i'm
going to bring my king in
b6 i'll take it
and yeah a6 so there you go so the line
that brian just said white is actually
winning here with this nice idea
uh b5
here
b6
and take and at first glance you might
think takes i'm just in time i'm in the
box but you can actually step past me
here
and now the black king is not going to
be able to catch this pawn so so white
does have a threat
so there's this c6 idea which seems to
be scary there's this a6 idea are there
any other ideas
there's really only one other one that's
possible
yeah play b5 let's say i bring my king
in
okay i'll do a little better
and yeah okay i mean you have c6 again
um but c6 maybe i have uh this move or
something to stay in the game
so the idea i wanted to highlight here
was that even b6 is going to be a little
bit scary because again
you have more breakthrough ideas with
these pawns coming through now in this
case this might not be
quite good enough but uh c6 a6 and b6
these are all the ideas you want to have
in mind
so we just calculated b6 or sorry c6
take b5 uh either take take or or not
b6 take a6 we lose
okay so that's priority number one we
have to deal with that threat so how do
we deal with the threat
you know we can't even worry about our
own pawns on the king's side yet we have
to make sure white just isn't making a
queen on us here
yeah king e7 you just bring the king
closer now let's calculate the same line
c6 b5
we can even take this time
b6 a6
i'm in time i'm gonna catch your pawn
uh so the breakthrough is no good for
white breakthroughs no good for white
so now
what should white do
what should white do
so i'm not going to tell you just yet
i'm going to show kingy or b5 was played
in the game
which is fine so now is is white making
a threat do we have to do anything on on
the queen side again
again let's say i pass
um
well is white able to break through
i'll give you a hint it's very similar
to what we just looked at right
yes
so
all right so how does he do it
you go c6 and it's it's just going to be
the same
take
b6
if we try to push past by the way b7 is
good
take a6 and we're outside the box
outside the box same as last time
so b5 makes a threat so what are we
gonna do
we'll just bring the king closer
perfectly fine again
okay now king e3 for white you know
white ran out of ways to make progress
over here a6 is is fine but you're just
going to get captured you know this is
no good for white this one i can just
take go here
again outside past pawn but it'll get
distracted i can win over here right f5
g4 h3 i'm definitely getting at least
one pass pawn over here i didn't ask you
to find that idea but hopefully that's
that's clear enough
so a6 is no good b6 is no good i push
past
and c6 is no good i can just take
right play b6 i take this guy
if you take i can even
separate your pawns and and win on this
side of the board
so none of those ideas are good for
white so white decides i'm going to
improve the king
and now
i make a i make a mistake here so i
played the most natural move of f5
but this is where this is the hardest
question of the night i think uh believe
it or not hardest question of the night
white to move i'm flipping the board
cause we're gonna be here for a while
white actually has
a way to draw the game pretty
immediately so white to move and draw
so to start with you want to ask
yourself what what are we trying to
to prevent so let's start with black's
ideas you know again let's say i pass
how is black gonna win
and i'll give you the hints king e2 not
the correct answer
so there you go
okay potentially uh but let's start with
the most natural moves so what's just
the the simplest most natural plan on
the board for for black
yeah you want to go g4
takes takes
and then let's say king of two
and by the way this might be what
happened in the game okay not quite
let's just show what happened in the
game so f5 king d4 was played
i went g4 takes takes came back to e3
so very very similar now
h3
uh okay h3 takes takes
you can try e5 right
but
turns out you're not quite in time in a
specific instance
but
what idea is sort of emerging here in
this position
right it's this floating square idea
that that we looked at now why is it the
why is the floating score idea emerging
because we're ending up with two past
pawns that are split by a couple files
so let's look at this position again
takes takes are we able to use this
floating square idea
to win the game here and how so
h3
okay can i get away with it what happens
here
so i think what you're suggesting is use
the floating square to determine
your move set right so
if
uh well let's stick with this and i'll
try to explain a little bit more clearly
um but what's happening here first of
all
e4 okay and like white goes here
e3 okay so it turns out black is
actually going to be winning in this
particular move order
right
so just just to show one more time
so what happens here well we see that we
have two past pawns one's gonna one is
on the e file one's going to be on the h
file no way to not have this pawn be
passed h3 is difficult to stop so what
we want to do is we want to get the pawn
to e4 so so that we have this nice
floating square
and you can achieve that by by playing
e5 in this position so e5
you know no matter what the king does
you can come to e4 then h3 and you can
still make this square
um if you play some other move i'm gonna
go e4
and again
nothing to do here for white you just go
h3
take take and and take
so that's the idea for black that's the
idea for black we want to in some
combination play this e5 move play g4
play h3 and and win the game
so my opponent in the game didn't quite
come up with with the right way to stop
me
um
so f4 and what's the idea
um
i
okay look at that
yeah so the problem here for black is
if black could play like e5 or something
then black might be winning but but what
happens if black tries to come this way
or maybe even like
tries to be a little bit clever about it
does something like this
yeah then again
same problems over here my king can't
come this far away
because i break through and win the game
so
um this position is actually just going
to be a draw the black king can't help
on on the king side white's going to
play king e5 king f4 forever uh and the
game is is just going to be a draw now
so f4 g takes f4 doesn't work but what
happens after g4 g4 seems like the more
natural idea
then i feel like we could just bring our
king back and then
um
yeah and that that's exactly right you
just come back with the king
and uh
and yeah now now this is just going to
be a draw so flip on the engine there's
there's just nothing to do if you play
h3 you actually probably lose the game
now with black because there's there's
nothing left to do
um so here uh f4 was was the magic move
now
just one more idea
what's going on in this position
just for fun
let's see if the floating square is
going to appear again
this one should be even more apparent
than the other floating squares in my
opinion at least
all right so white is actually going to
be winning here again
and this is the mystical floating square
that i was hoping you might might pick
out
yeah you were looking for black i i get
it but just for example even if we pass
with black here uh it's a good point
that's
uh the square is not gonna be reaching
the end of the board for for black white
is able to step here
and these two pawns actually do defend
each other in this configuration i can
never take here or else black is gonna
queen and i can't come after this other
guy but you know i'm not losing on this
side of the board i can pass like this
forever
um but in the meantime white is actually
just winning again with the same
breakthrough idea
the point now being that i can't come to
take this pawn because then this pawn
will run in the other direction
and it's pretty clear that that white is
going to be queening
in this position
so
that was the the big idea in this end
game king e3 f5 f4 was the only move but
things get a little bit more complicated
if i come up with the move f6 so after
f6 the the last thing i wanted you guys
to try to find if i can
cheat a little bit more here i believe
that the only move to draw the game here
is the kind of amazing move g4
so what is the point of playing g4 in in
this position
what is the points well the point is now
you're making sure that black's past
pawns are not separated they're not able
to make this big floating square uh why
not well because we can't make a past
pawn on the e file anymore we can take
this guy
and black can even just come all the way
down with pawn to f4
but the point is uh as i was saying
now these pawns are are all together
and i especially like highlighting this
example
because it's my favorite thing in the
world
to look
at at these end games
all right does anybody recognize this
type of setup here with the three pawns
versus the lone king very long time
viewers of the lectures might recognize
this
uh about a full year ago now i would say
i taught a lecture on what used to be a
wild variant on icc where you just start
with three white pawns versus three
black pawns and and two kings
and so those ideas almost showed up in
this real game
of course here though white is just
going to be winning because you are not
able to quite promote the king is able
to stop all three pawns
just barely
why is the king able to stop all three
pawns
uh well because the it's just well
placed okay so that's the last thing i
wanted to highlight you know white has
this amazing move g4 and the point is
even though you are
uh sacrificing
uh one of your remaining pawns on the
king's side the point is you're grouping
the black pawns together and that's
going to allow the the white king to
effectively stop all of them uh not
something you might expect
uh and that is the story of this king
and pawn end game uh by the way though
if you're curious how this game ended it
was a blitz game i didn't find any of
these ideas we shuffled around forever
just just kept shuffling and then
eventually and then eventually i was
like okay white played g3 which made my
job a lot easier so i played h3 this is
obviously just winning now i made a
queen
and checkmate of my opponent so not the
best wolf not the best played game but a
very very interesting king and pawn end
game that arose uh and i think that's
about all i've got for you guys tonight
so thank you all for coming out do you
have any questions before we we wrap up
here
all right well well thank you very much
hopefully you learned something about
how to apply these more basic concepts
to more complicated end games
floating square idea the outside past
pawn mutual zooxvong breakthrough ideas
all of these are showing up constantly
in these complicated king pawn end games
uh with that i wanna thank you guys very
much for joining me here tonight that is
all i have for you if you're watching
live or online be sure to stick around
for alex lenderman's
insane in the end game class it's gonna
be a blast more end games more fun
all right as always thank you very much
for watching my name is caleb denby and
i will see you next time
[Music]
you